hey everyone it's Sarah threats Turner
sorry and calm and in this video I want
to demonstrate for you the lead
placement for a 12-lead EKG first you
want to gather your supplies so you
don't want to get 10 of these electrode
stickers next you'll want to get some
alcohol prep this will help you remove
those oils from that top layer of the
skin so the electrode stickers will
stick then you'll want to get a strip of
abrasive tape which is just really this
little fine gritty sand paper stuff that
you'll use to rough up that top layer of
the epidermis so these electrodes will
stick to now if you're doing this on a
patient who has a lot of hair on their
chest you'll want to get some trimmers
to trim that hair because sticking these
electrode stickers over hair does not
work and it causes a lot of artifacts so
you'll want to trim those hairs okay so
the first thing what we're gonna do is
we're gonna place our limb leads which
are which include our right arm or left
arm or right leg and our left leg and
then we will place our limb leads which
will be v2 through v6 okay whenever
you're placing limb leads you can either
put them on the chest which you're gonna
see me doing this video or you can put
them on the extremities from where I
worked in a stress lab we always use the
chest for the limb leads because the
patient was going to be exercising and
when you exercise you move your arms and
legs and that can cause a lot of
artifact so to do the right arm we're
gonna go right below the right clavicle
and what we want to do is we want to
prep that site you're going to take some
alcohol prep cleanse it very well
removing any oils from the skin let that
dry then take your brace of tape and
just gently rough up the skin that top
layer so the sticker will sit good to it
the electrode and each electrode has
backing so you're gonna peel that
backing off like that has like this gel
and make sure they're not dry if they're
really dry looking get new electrodes
because it'll affect your connection and
you're just gonna put that there and
just smooth it on the skin now we're
gonna put our left arm and you're going
to do the same prep cleanse the skin
with alcohol prep rough it up we're on
Rob below
that left clavicle and then we're gonna
put our electrode okay now let's do our
leg leads okay we're gonna do the right
leg so we're going to go down to the
right upper quadrant and again you could
place this on the leg I'm going to
cleanse the area I'm going to gently
rough up the skin and put our electrode
and we're going in the right upper
quadrant now we're gonna do the last leg
we're gonna go in the left upper
quadrant again cleanse the area rough up
the skin and place our electrode now
let's place our test leads which again
is v1 through v6 and to do that we need
to find our intercostal spaces and it's
best to follow this way of identifying
the landmarks to find why intercostal
space you're in so first what we're
gonna do is we're gonna find the sternal
notch which is literally is a notch and
it's found in between the clavicles and
then you're gonna go down just slightly
and you're gonna feel this protrusion a
little hump this is called the angle of
Lewis also called the sternal angle and
we're gonna place v1 first so we're
gonna go to the right of that angle and
we're going to be in the second
intercostal space
now v1 is in the fourth intercostal
space right of the sternum so we're
gonna go down there's a third there's
the fourth so we're in the fourth
intercostal space and this is where v1
is gonna go slightly just next to the
sternum
so again just gonna cleanse the area
really good rough it up and then place
your electrode okay now v2 is going to
be literally right beside of it on the
opposite side it's going to be again
buying your sternal notch go down where
the hump is which is your angle of Luis
from the
second intercostal space third and then
fourth and it's going to be on the left
side so cleanse the area and rough it up
then place your electrode
okay so right now we have v1 and v2 okay
we're gonna skip v3 for a second you're
gonna see why we're gonna go to v4 v 4
is found at that fifth intercostal space
so again find your landmarks second
third fourth fifth and we're gonna go
mid clavicular ly so mid way of the
clavicle and it's going to be right here
so that is going to be v4 so we're gonna
cleanse the skin rough it up and then
we're going to place our electrode okay
and now we're going to go back to V 3
and V 3 is in between v2 and v4 so we're
going to go right there so we're gonna
cleanse the skin wrap it up place our
electrode okay so we have v1 v2 v3 v4
now we're going to do these five and
these five is going to be level with v4
but it's going to be at the left
anterior mid-axillary line so right here
so cleanse area fit up man we're going
to place our electrode okay and our last
one is v6 and these six is going to be
level with v5 but it's gonna be at the
mid-axillary line so literally right
underneath the armpit so it's going to
be
right here so we're going to cleanse it
up our electrode okay
so let's go over them again we have our
limb leads right arm left arm right leg
left leg now we have our test leads we
have the 1 v2 v3 v4 v5 and v6 ok so that
is the lead placement for a 12 lead EKG
thank you so much for watching and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more videos